marc coma ist grafikdesigner seine
freizeit verbringt er am liebsten in der
küche
er schreibt den block baic zu berufs-
und diese seite wurde schon mehrfach in
deutschland prämiert
dahinter verbirgt sich ein wahres
hüftgold paradies von der
zitronenthymian tat bis zum fruchtigen
käsekuchen
wer sich durch marc thomas rezepte
klickt dem läuft schon beim lesen das
wasser im mund zusammen
doch bevor die rezepte online gehen muss
marc roma erst einmal selbst an die
rührschüssel heute gibt es etwas hippes
ein hybrid örtchens correns sie sind
einfach super lecker das ist so eine
mischung aus horror und machen nicht
ganz so fett ist aber seit vier jahren
schreibt marc coma seinen blog als er
anfing fürs netz zu backen hatte er
nicht damit gerechnet über so lange zeit
erfolgreich dabei zu sein
nun hat er auf instagram mehr als 33.000
abonnenten doch typisch deutsch backt er
nicht
[Musik]
ich habe am beispiel usa gelebt und
gearbeitet hat mich da im cup cakes
verliebt und die gab es damals in
deutschland noch nicht und haben
angefangen die sachen selbst zu backen
zu hause und hatte immer so ein bisschen
probleme mit den rezepten weil es
verschiedene sachen nicht gab an zutaten
und hab dann sachen ersetzt und sachen
aufgeschrieben und dachte irgendwann
könnte die anderen leuten genauso gehen
angefangen hat alles aufzuschreiben und
irgendwann ins internet gestellt der
crafter teig muss jetzt eine weile gehen
zeit um sich den block zu widmen
viel arbeit steckt darin bis zu 16
stunden verbringt er damit in der woche
drei neue rezepte stellt hätten online
aber nur wenn sie seinen gaumen test
bestanden haben was macht er mit dem
rest der teig ist soweit jetzt noch
ausrollen dass zimt und zucker bestreuen
wieder einrollen schneiden und ab in die
förmchen damit für 25 minuten geht es
nun in den ofen bei 200 grad celsius ein
spannender moment denn auch den besten
gelingt nicht immer alles ja ich habe
mal versucht cookies ohne mehl zu machen
und das war einfach furchtbar zerbröselt
ohne ende und deswegen nicht nieder ohne
waffen
bei den treffens läuft alles wie geplant
wenn sie aus dem ofen kommen durfte der
raum nach butter und hefe
am besten sind sie lauwarm aber marx
roma kann noch nicht naschen
schließlich müssen auch fotos er wie
gesagt eine menge aufwand mit dem blog
aber die ideen gehen ihm nicht aus
als nächstes cups mit eis das sich die
kleinen kennen vielleicht so torres aus
spanien gibt es mal ein langer form und
ich hab's gemacht raus und in die
philipp moser ist was erstmal chrome us
open kommt sieht nicht nur gut aus auch
das nachbacken lohnt sich
[Musik]